Republicans are making serious inroads
with the fastest growing voting group
and Democrats are already playing the
blame game turns out Democrats have been
taking Latino voters for granted when it
comes to their top issues inflation
crime and immigration and AOC is lashing
out at our own party for never making an
effort
I can at least say with latino voters
we've never tried as a party
the Democratic party has not tried in in
terms of Latino electorates and I mean
where's our Dream Act where is our
immigration reform we really need to
step up both in our efforts on campaign
but also our efforts and governance
but msnbc's Joy Reid is in complete
denial and thanks the mainstream media
thinks the mainstream media is just
hyping the story
there is this thing that's happening in
the mainstream media that they say oh um
Hispanic voters are going Republican as
if they are now a solid Republican group
because you do have some South Texas
counties that are shifting red I've been
pulling my hair out for the last couple
of months as I've seen story after story
after story that you mentioned acting as
though the Latino vote is somehow firmly
a Republican vote now which couldn't be
further from the truth because when you
pull it Latinos are still firmly
democratic
okay I'll start with you Jesse I mean
the truth is that we've even reported
that there's an increase of Latino
voters uh going toward the Republicans
and they act like we're making this
stuff up yeah they do well they should
be worried the Democrats made a mistake
because they tried to lump blacks in
with Hispanics and tried to pitch them
the same way but the black experience in
America is different than the Hispanic
experience their family trees are
different the Hispanic family tree is
complicated you have light-skinned
Hispanics that Trace their lineage back
to European Spain you have darker
skinned Hispanics that have more of an
indigenous background Puerto Rico is
different than Cuba Central America is
different than South America and then
you have second and third generation
Hispanics here that are very assimilated
and then you have migrants that just got
here and so the Democrats try to pitch
Hispanics by using the big government
race card play that they use on blacks
and it's not working because economics
especially inflation in crime Trump's
identity politics and it's turned
Hispanics into swing voters now
Hispanics are up for grabs and that
would be a death blow to the Democrat
Party Coalition how do they explain Myra
Flores who you know is now running for
congress having won the primary and by
the way she uh she won that special seat
she won the special receipt right but
she the Congressional Hispanic caucus
rejected her as a member is it are you
considered Latina if you are a Democrat
but not if you're a republican you know
I don't know the answer the question
I'll say they're light-skinned blacks
I'm one of them and they're dark skin
black side as well but I understand I
understand the point I understand the
point that I don't see color I
understand the point that you're making
and I happen to happen I think Democrats
and Republicans have to realize with
every Community you have to have a
continuous conversation and engagement
with blacks with whites with Latinas
with Hispanics all voters and when you
begin to take them for granted and think
45 days up from election you can put a
massive get out the vote effort and
hopefully that group goes out to vote
for you if that's the only engagement
then you're going to run into these
challenges that I don't often agree with
the congresswoman I think I understand
what she's saying you cannot say well
they've never campaigned I think there's
a laziness amongst some Democrats and
some democratic strategists about how
you go about engaging communities of
color particularly Black and Hispanic
voters Black and Hispanic voters are
interested in crime we're interested in
inflation we're interested in National
Security we want clean energy but we
also want energy that is plentiful you
have to have the same conversation with
those voters you have with every other
voter and when you start trying to
subset and figure out how you maybe
angle here to talk to this group of
Voters you're going to run the risk of
doing I think what the congresswoman was
trying to say which is alienating people
and maybe even pushing them to the other
party yeah well don't call them tacos
Jill Biden learned that yeah
um breakfast you know Dana the truth is
that
with the number of blacks and Hispanics
who are moving toward the Republican
party I think whatever that number is
there is a movement and low voter
turnout I think that that might be part
of the argument that AOC is making that
but do you think that there is a
motivation on the part of the Democrats
to have a high voter turnout well I I
think that one I've never heard her
praise anyone she's just complains about
everybody and I would Point her to Dan
balls of the Washington Post a veteran
reporter he just did a very deep dive on
Hispanic voters in Nevada and that is a
senate seat that they are likely to lose
and most of it will be in Nevada because
of Latino voters moving towards them and
I don't know why you guys are laughing
but you can tell me the commercial
breaks the other thing is let's be
honest here that they are departing
mostly based on economic issues so if
you push the green New Deal and you want
to take away their jobs you want to
change agriculture you want to change
the way they even refer to themselves
and make them call themselves latinx
they they have abandoned the party on
the they've abandoned Latinos on on that
I will point out that if the Stanford
Business School shows that Latino
communities are the ones that are the
most entrepreneurial who was hurt the
most during the coveted lockdowns those
entrepreneurs and so they're not going
to forget that you can't just show up
and say well you can't vote because
Republican because you never have that's
just not going to work with people and I
also think that the school issue is a
really big one when Glenn Younkin won a
lot of Hispanic votes in Virginia part
of the reason was because he said I will
make sure that advanced math is taught
in school that kids are going to be
reading at grade level because the
parents want their kids to do very well
um all right Greg you know part of part
of what AOC is complaining about is when
when she when the President issued that
uh pardon for those people who were in
prison for marijuana possession she
wanted it to extend to undocumented
individuals and she's very upset with
the Joe Biden for that yeah boy in the
end how does it play out I don't know
judge but I as you know I identify as
latinx
on certain adult websites I do anyway
I don't I'm we're I'm wondering what she
has done for Latinos she's killed
thousands of jobs that would have
directly benefited Latinos in her
District she said nothing about crime I
haven't heard anything especially crime
affecting women she she actually said to
your point I hate saying that all she
does is say you you you and you go well
what about you and she has nothing I
think what she's saying and I'm reading
her mind here which is hard to do but uh
maybe what she's saying is she wants
Latinos to be turned into a homogenized
voting block that Dems can count on no
matter what I think that's all it is and
she's trying to figure out why Latinos
are resistant to being part of the
victim class like why like they've been
left us spent decades decades trying to
get blacks to be seen as as an oppressed
group so they don't ever leave and I
think that she's watching The Exodus
she's watching people leave and she's
saying you know what we don't have a
strong grip on Latinos how do we get
them to think that we're their savior
they won't because their savior is
religion family working it's not the
kind of it's not Progressive politics
and I think she might be perceptive
enough to realize the progressive woke
ideology is doesn't work and it's not
working on blacks either if you talk to
blacks they don't don't like you're like
this is just for white liberals this is
for guilty white liberals hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else